hallo liebe Lena hallo sicherlich
gehörst du zu den meist befragtesten
Menschen zurzeit in der Republik und der
christoph hat mich gefragt ob ich dir
nicht auch noch eine Frage stellen will
ich habe es auch schon probiert und hab
dann gesagt ah nee es ist irgendwie
Quatsch das einzige was ich die
vielleicht fragen würde weil es mich
privat wirklich interessiert ist wie
gehst du mit diesem Lampenfieber um dass
du haben musst sonst bist du ein
Übermensch wenn du das nicht hast bei
diesen Wahnsinns Geschichten die in
letzter Zeit erlebt hast mit Vorauswahl
und Kontest und Abitur und all diese
Menschen die so viel von dir wollen wie
machst du das wo steckst du das hin
m was denkst du wenn du abends allein im
Hotelbett kurz vom Einschlafen bis das
würde mich interessieren ja die die
lampenfieberfrage die hatten wir ja
schon lieber Oliver dann guck dir doch
mal die Folge an dann hast du diese
Frage schon
beantwortet und die nächste Frage war
die hotelbettfrage richtig ich bin ich
bin sehr froh dass ich ein kleines
Appartement hier habe und Gott sei Dank
nicht immer im Hotelbett schlafen muss
m deswegen fühle ich mich fühle ich mich
zu Hause und wohler als als in dem
Hotelbett
was was soll ich was soll ich dir sagen
was ich denke also wenn ich frei habe
dann denke ich meistens den ganzen Tag
darüber nach was ich so mache und was
ich lasse und was ich machen könnte und
was ich so gemacht habe und wenn ich
nicht frei habe dann ist ein Tag
meistens so anstrengend dass ich abends
gar nicht mehr denken
kann so ist
es